understanding South Africa's genocide
case against Israel part three the
evidence now that we're up to speed on
the context let me show you what's in
this 84-page document accusing Israel of
genocide the case starts right away with
their main argument that the acts by
Israel are genocidal in character
because they are intended to bring about
the destruction of the Palestinians and
then they list the genocidal acts in
question they argue that Israeli
officials have been publicly calling for
genocide there's an entire section with
statements from the Israeli president
prime minister and the military that
South Africa is saying proves this this
is important because as we talked about
in part two the definition legally of
genocide must include an explicit intent
to destroy Palestinians page 30 kind of
gets to the heart of this case killing
over 21,000 Palestinians including 8,000
children injuring 55,000 displacing 85%
of the population attacking hospitals
and pushing Palestinians quote to the
brink of famine there's obviously much
more to this case that I can cover here
and I suggest that you read it on your
own